[Music]
hey guys in this video we are going to
talk about one of the most insane
theories see no game turns and why fans
claim that brain stark equals the xix
theory has been confirmed to come true
let's first take a look on this popular
theory it says that at some point we
will arrive at the end of game dreams
and probably many deaths will take place
that's when Brandon Starks son of error
to start decides he'll travel back in
time and try to stop the knight king's
army in the events from taking place
when the three-eyed raven says you will
never walk again but you will fly he
means through time and not only working
in dragon like many fans believed there
was a reason Jojen Reed who also had the
green site and know even more things
about it and brain did not become the
three-eyed Raven himself the reason is
that brain is even more powerful than
both Jojen and the three-eyed Raven
Brian rivers invaded his both green site
and the ability to work but his
combination brain is even able to affect
the past by working in two villas and
eventually making him become horror
which pros the ink is dry he also gains
his father's attention outside the Tower
of joy and even gets touched by the
knight King in one of his green sites
brain believes he's eventually with more
knowledge going to be able to rewrite
history and that's why he decides to go
back and stop the night King several
times but fails every time ending up
fulfilling the timeline circle and
taking the identity of the knight King
himself the first time he tries to
prepared Mad King Ford White Walkers and
makes him to the same whisper method
used to get Ned's attention repair
wildfire under King's Landing
or the White Walkers attacked this
attack is in the future forest viewers
but brain fails as the Mad King goes
crazy front whispers and instant tries
to burn the city the second time brain
goes even more beyond back in time as he
learns his abilities he's able to go
longer and longer back in time to try
discover how the others were defeated
the first time he fails again and
instead succeeds to become bran the
Builder
building the wall and securing his birth
by building Winterfell and waiting the
words there must always be a stark
meaningful the last time brain goes back
hold wait where deny King was created to
work in the human the leader is going to
become the night King or maybe even try
to kill the children of the forest he
works interim instead of stopping
journalist into the heart event from
happening or maybe in his attempt to
kill
children he gets chosen as the vessel
for the night king only he does not
think of that the children of forests
will not recognize him from the future
and the day at that point are in more
with the first men
he's gagged because all of the weird
future talk when he realized he failed
again he tries to go back in the current
timeline but can because he's too deep
into the past and stayed too long
it's beautiful beneath the sea stay too
long in you drown from your brain get
stuck in the past exactly as brining and
Georgian warned him not to and he comes
the night king with the combination of
the children's magic and brains power he
becomes the villain instead of the hero
he tried to be resulting in turning
against the children for creating him
and getting stuck behind magical wall he
later bailed says bran the Builder
immortal as he is he waits for himself
to be born thousands of years later
knowing when and where he has to be to
mark the young brain first only killed
it read Raven for hiding truth about
what would happen to him and eventually
being able to destroy the wall with his
Aryan the reason he doesn't kill John
and instead observe him at heart calm
will be covered in the end it's most
likely because he knows only John can
kill him the night king is brain and
he's marching south to kill the actual
brain so the brain doesn't go back and
become the night King because bran going
back is what made bran become the night
king you can actually see in the scene
where young brain goes back to the
creation of the night king that when the
children push the dragon glass into his
heart we see brain tighten his grip on
his veins
just as it's himself experiencing the
pain also at the end of the flashback
brain is laying in the exact same
position in the cave as the human pushed
up to the trees this theory also parts
we jump something the prince that was
promised who eventually has to kill his
little brother brain giving us a
bittersweet ending the first time fans
sorry claiming this theory was confirmed
is rangamma term stars for posing with
miniature versions of themselves on
official Game of Thrones Instagram
profile an actor who plays brain star
post with the 19 miniature living fans
convinced that it's a huge gain top film
actual being tonight king many fans were
commenting brain spoiler wise brain
holding the night king Brandon night
King spoiler alert etc etc now I'm not
saying this theory will not come true
but this photo most definitely is not
hinting it coming true as many fans
claim in the series of photos there's
also an actress who plays insane day
holding dragon and sophie turner holding
Rams a miniature does that mean Sandy's
dragon or senses Ramsay no and therefore
this photo was a crate holding the night
king means nothing in him
nothing not saying the theory is not
going to come true just saying this
photo is not hinting it not to say
confirming it NuWave offense claiming
the brain star cake was denied king
confirmed came up in a recently released
season 80s in each fence notice brands
absence fans immediately started
claiming it means that the popular
theory is now finally confirmed with
many commenting on the official tease
brain is denied king confirmed do I
think it's been confirmed
definitely not confirmed may be hinted
but most probably not even that the
teaser revolves around the stark family
so brands explosion is curious and could
definitely point to a couple of
different theories about this
character's part in the end game brands
absence could also hint that him not
surviving the coming battles instead
dying alongside Annette King in his army
or if we want to remain optimistic we
can speculate that the three-eyed Raven
dies my brain as he once was lives to
stay the spring however most fans claim
that the brains absence point out of him
being the night king in my opinion brain
earth being in stark teases representing
symbolism the taste has a lot of
symbolism let's take a look at some of
those symbolisms and what i can tell us
about what's to come in the final season
the significance of the crypts the
crypts of NFL is an ideal setting for
the final season trailer the location
being full of significance for the stars
it's there that sharks are buried and
the kings in northern Lords of
Winterfell are honored with statues its
appeared a few times drug shows run
almost always first scene that looks
towards the past this alone tells us
that the final season will be shifting a
lot of focus back to the Starks there
how this story started so it's fitting
it ends with them as well the crypts may
be a place that's full of death but it
also speaks to the porn so family above
all else something Starks need to
remember now more than ever
Jon might even learn the truth behind
his parentage in the crypts this teaser
also symbolizes winter coming to Minerva
while the teaser mostly focuses on stars
it ends with a palpable sense of dread
as the cold winds blow the crypts are
frosting over her holding the arrival of
inter at Winterfell
not winter as in the season which has
already come but as in the undead the
season Sam finale and it with the nat
king using bazarian to break down the
wall and the army of the Dead is making
their slow march of doom toward the
stark homestead whenif alden is going to
play home to some by walkers and whites
although it's fair to assume they won't
be protected by guests right when FL is
going to be a setting for the biggest
battle Sirius has ever done which we'll
see John and company battling the Nike
and it serves as a nice little tease of
that coming fight then we have the
better in this theater trailer Lena
statue is holding a feather that floats
out of her hand when John walks by the
first time we see this patter is in
season one when Robert Baratheon places
it only in a statue it appears again in
season five and sensor visits her hands
to resting place we later see Sansa
wearing the feather on her sleeve during
a scene at Marina
what became of the adornment afterwards
is unknown but symbolically the feather
is important to sense as well as John it
plays into the bird imagery in both
characters arts John formerly of the
Nights Watch was called a crow and since
has been called little bird or a little
doll and feathers were a prominent piece
in a costume as Elaine stone if we are
to assume that the feather is symbolic
of Joshua parentage it's fallen the new
teaser represents the reveal of that
secret in season 8 since the safekeeping
in season 5 could have foreshadow a
reunion with John and relationship
afterwards she kept the north loyal to
him in his absence and will likely do
the same one sister Gary and bloodline
becomes known in season 7 stark
bannermen were clear that they would not
abide their gaming role so just a sense
appease them in season 7 she'll be
instrumental in ensuring their continued
loyalty to him when they learn John
Isner Ned Stark's son after all the next
are statues of John Orion sense savage
hints at our fates each of the stars
that appeared in teaser gets a statue in
each statue contains details that can be
read into how I say it is that these
statues of John's centenary are their
actual statue shattered their death
however not all of them will die season
8 and at all these statues will be seen
during season 8 just take a look at John
statue John snow gets to grow old or at
least a bit older than he currently is
given how deadly the final season is
going to be the idea this teaser is
telling us just arrives is a big deal
has already died once at all and this is
history above all others if this teaser
for share of something is the Johnston's
arrived the game turns to live until the
very old age
well John statue looks old arias is
young although the stonework is still a
little off she definitely looks to be
around the same age as there is now
which is not exactly happy for sharing
the most obvious point here is that it
means Sariah dies in season 8 that's not
much of a stretch to imagine since Arya
will be on the battlefield fighting
against my walkers so life is very much
a risk and if she were to die it's
fitting that her remaining siblings
would want to
with the statue the spider not being a
queen or lady much like man did with his
sister there's another slightly more
optimistic meaning optimistic in a sense
that she doesn't die at least Aria has
trained her the faceless man so this
could instead suggest she leaves her
Aria face behind taking Oh Marius new
identities for what remains of her life
the trouble with that is it betrays her
arc over the last couple of seasons
which were all about her reclaiming her
identity but it could be about finding a
balance between being Aria and being a
faceless man last we come to sense a
statue which again looks roughly the
same age as a character does now
although she could be a little older
what's most interesting about Sansa in
this teaser is that both living version
instead sure placed in metal Chanin Aria
in death they're flanking our side in
live they're joining their swords ready
to protect her that could quite simply
be down to the fact that she's their
sister doesn't have a weapon and is not
a trained fighter like they are but the
way it's framed and in interests of some
speculation made here in the middle and
slightly behind the others is very much
how we'd see people protecting their
Queen once the war is done we'll see
Sansa take on the role of Queen in the
north
either bestowed upon her by John could
have a different throne evading him
anyway finally we come to brain stark
him what his absence might symbolize
image or defense turned out to be
correct then this absence symbolizes him
being the night king but in my opinion
it symbolizes him not being brain stark
in my opinion the reason brain is not in
this state is because he's not a stark
anymore
he's not brain stark as he said himself
in season 7 brain is fully the
three-eyed raven there's no sign of
brain anywhere in this teaser but then
that just serves as a reminder or even a
confirmation that brain is not a stark
anymore he was well on his way to fully
become the three-eyed raven in season
seven telling meera he wasn't really
brain now this teaser doesn't have a
statue of him in the crypts he's not a
stark anymore brains burn is not to live
on forever
single things does the previous three
eyed Raven did before him until someone
kills him it should come in very handy
for the Battle of Ice and Fire
one might suggest a pretty lonely
existence beyond that then again I might
be wrong maybe this teaser truly
confirmed that Brent Stark is in fact
the night king as many fans claim the
theory itself sounds interesting and
there's plenty of hints and clues
supporting it after all they've been
promised the bittersweet ending John
hood pledged his life for House Stark
ending up killing its last male heir to
integrate
war would surely fulfill that
bittersweet ending better dead John had
to kill brain start but sweet that the
living has won Westeros is saved and
John is finally ended brands misery let
me know your thoughts about all of this
in the comment section down below and as
always I hope you guys enjoyed this
video if you did please make sure to
subscribe to our Channel and I hope to
see you in the next one peace